[Music]
so you want clams for dinner this blue
crab does but she doesn't need frying or
breadcrumbs in fact she'll just take
care of removing the shell herself
we know this crab is a female by the red
tips on her claws while we may use some
small tools to eat crab claws ourselves
the crab uses its claws as a tool to
pick apart and remove the meaty part of
the clam and as you can see it's a
tedious process that takes some time
anyone who's eaten a crab claw can
relate to having to work for your meal
blue crabs not only eat clams but they
eat other shellfish too like oysters and
mussels they'll eat almost any vegetable
matter or animal preferably dead or
recently dead
sometimes even young crabs and just like
one of those crab restaurants with
newspapers on the tables where they
don't mind if shell pieces end up on the
floor the crab leaves its scraps on the
floor to the ocean floor
[Music]